On this episode, we take a bunch of
questions from Chinese students.
(Upbeat intro)
♫ Hey!
♫ Gary Vee!
-[Gary] ♫ You ask questions
♫  and I answer them.
♫ This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey, everybody!
This is
Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is
episode 259 of
"The #AskGaryVee Show"
.
live from my hotel room
in Hong Kong.
The "Asian Invasion" is
underway, DRock.
Singapore in October.
I might have just committed to
going to Beijing on that
same trip. January.
I have been long waiting.
I left you guys a little bit of a clue
in Canne, of my great ambition
to enter the Asian market.
And I'm excited about it,
and the trip here has been remarkable.
I'm completely infatuated and
in love with Hong Kong, and
I've got 7 to 15 more incredible
cities that I will attack,
address, and visit over the
next 4 to 5,  6 months.
DRock, pick up the
camera now and show
two of our 3 or 4
homies that help us.
Say "hello!", guys.
-[Skipper] Hello!
- [Rhys]  Hello, how are you, everyone!
Vayner Nation, what's up!
-[Gary] These are two amazing
teammates on a team
that has helped Sid on our end
translate my content,
create opportunities. This episode
is extremely special because
they helped curate an
opportunity of what is it,
5 or 6? 5 or 6 questions from
Shanghai Tech University
students, which I'm going
to answer right now.
I appreciate that guys,
and I want to publicly appreciate
you guys for all the
hard work and the hustle.
As you could tell by
the meeting we had earlier,
there's a lot more to go,
and so this should be
a pretty awesome journey.
-[Skipper] (Inaudible)
-[Gary] Yes, agree. (laughter)
DRock, good trip so far?
-[DRock] Great.
Phenomenal.
-[Gary] Fun trip.
All right. Let's get right
into the first question.
- [Haolong] Hello, Gary!
I'm Haolong.
.
I'm so glad that I
can have the chance to
talk to you through
the video.
Before I start my question,
let me just briefly
introduce myself so that
that you can have a
general idea on my background.
I'm a senior to be
undergraduate student from
Shanghai Tech University,
and is now studying at
Harvard as a visiting
undergraduate. I'm majoring
in biology, while I'm also
a big fan of entrepreneurship
and management.
Because personally, I consider
entrepreneurship and science
as something closely related.
Say, for scientists,
actually they need to think
from an entrepreneur point of view
so that your discoveries can be
made into something useful.
While for the entrepreneurs,
sometimes they do need
advanced scientific tools to
make their normal ideas into reality.
The good thing is that from
the past decades,
we do see a lot of good examples
where people combine entrepreneurship
and science together,
typically in the IT field.
However, the interesting phenomenon
is that in the field of biology,
this philosophy doesn't
work well for some reason.
My question is just,  "What do you
think might  be the main factors
that caused these phenomena
in the bio world?"
And also, from your point of view,
"What do you consider as the biggest,
also the most promising
opportunities in the field of biology
in the following two or three decades?"
Looking forward to your reply and many thanks.
- [Gary] Haolong, thank you so much
for the question.
This is going to be a fun episode.
I have a feeling everybody's going to
enjoy these video questions.
Look, I think the reason that you're
seeing a lot of people in the biology sector,
...biotech,  things of that nature...
struggle is at people hold onto romance.
People hold on to the establishment.
The decision makers in your field
often times don't want to change.
In entrepreneurship --
that energy is always disruptive,
and often times takes people that
are on a pedestal, off that pedestal.
There's human behaviors of defense.
You have to understand that once
somebody is at a pedestal that they feel is
the height of where they are,
they start going on defense
and not letting anybody
take them off.
They're not continuing to aspire.
I believe a lot of it
is human inefficiency.
As far as open opportunities,
the truth is, I believe that
in the biology, what you see
because of technology and the
internet infrastructure --- the
enormous advances we have
in science is,
everything is vulnerable.
I often say in entrepreneurship,
which I understand much better than biology,
that Amazon put bookstores
on notice early.
Uber put car service, black limo
companies, cab services on notice.
But everybody is vulnerable.
I would argue because of the
advances in technology, literally
everything in every sector is
today vulnerable over the next
two decades.  And so for me,
I would take your energy
and deploy it against the thing
you're most passionate about.
Because it inevitably will be disrupted
over the next two to three decades.
- [Yang] Hey, Gary!
This is Yang from Shanghai.
I have a question.
For AI startup, it's very difficult
for them to collect a lot
a lot of data in their
first 3 or 5 years, and
they really need these data to
improve their products in the algorithm.
Big companies like Google-
they already have a lot of data
and they can develop similar
products using this data easily.
"What's your advice for these
AI startups?" Thank you!
- [Gary] Chen Yang, my advice is to
not fight Google in a game
that Google is more likely to win.
The number one rule I have about
startups and entrepreneurs is
when David is fighting Goliath,
you never fight Goliath's game.
Your question, if anybody was
paying attention to, makes this very easy,
which is: Creating a business
that is vulnerable to the
Google infrastructure or any other
company for that matter,
whether it's Amazon or Apple or Facebook.
It's just not smart, and so what
you need to do, is you find small niches
that either you hope you can
move so quickly in, that by the
time they decide to attack it,
they're better to acquire you.
Or that you've amassed so much
market share that you'll be able to
sustain the blow of that competition,
and that whatever you're left with,
once they enter, will still be meaningful.
Very similar to the case study.
I'll give you a great one.
The case study is Compaq Computers
versus IBM in the 80's.
They found their niches.
They found their product fit,
and they were able to go up
against "The Big Blue Giant".
Then they also used software
companies like Microsoft
to really democratize and create a
huge opportunity and they teamed up
with their competition. I think if you
want to spend time on Google
or whatever search engine
you'd like,  to look at the
Compaq Computer story of how
they were able to navigate and
grow to such a ... That is a perfect story
and we see it everyday.
It's speed. Only speed
trumps somebody that's bigger
than a giant. Play your game,
and so find niches and go extremely
fast. Otherwise you have no shot.
-[DRock] (Inaudible) ...Compaq.
-[Gary] Good story.
Yeah, you should really look into it.
- [Background conversation]
(Inaudible)
- [Rhys] ...She said she's
a biology student as well...
(Sound of Gary's laptop keyboard.
Clack, clickety-clack)
- [Zicheng]
...As a biology major
student, I'm also very
interested  in art and
design and
entrepreneurship even.
I'm sometimes very confused about
what I will do and what I will become
after I enter to the society.
However, I really have a sense
and motivation to combine all
I Iearned and what I like to
one thing, which is something
I don't know and maybe combined
by something that is very irrelevant.
So sometimes I'm really lost.
Can you give me some suggestions?
- [Gary] I sure can.
Yeah, I mean look. The good
news  is 90% of all students
don't know what to do,
and everybody's overthinking it.
So what I would tell..my friend is,
you need to really look inside your
heart and figure out what - she-
When you talk to yourself,
what does -she- want to do?
I would tell you that the number one
thing that you should focus on is doing.
You're not going to figure this out
being in your own head.
Just start doing. Do it all.
Do some of it together.
Mix art and bio[logy].
Mix entrepreneurship and music.
Just  do do do do do!!
Do you understand how young you are?
Do you understand that you can
just "do" for the next 10 years?
Do and do and do.
Try some company for 3 years.
Try some internship for two years.
Try some medical sabbatical for 4 years.
You wake up from those 9 years,
and you're 31-years-old. You're a baby.
You're going to have a very
difficult time in getting me upset
or be empathetic to being crippled
by having all these interests.
Put them all together. Separate them apart.
Spend the next decade, I mean that,
tasting and trying. The problem is,
you come from an environment where
people are going to be judging you
if you're not succeeding in the short-term.
And that is your vulnerability.
The judgment of society:
Your parents or somebody else to--
as you're trying and failing
until you find your things.
You may be lucky and your first thing
maybe the great thing. You may
be lucky in your fourth thing.
And I said that on purpose slowly.
You may be lucky it's the first thing.
You may be lucky it's the fourth thing.
But you have to have the internal
strength to be able to hold off
society and family judgment while you
navigate. If you're so confused,
well then you need to do
something about it.
The answer is to do a bunch of stuff
over the next decade to put yourself
in a position in your early 30s
to enjoy your world. I get that...
Listen,  I've been doing a lot of data
collecting here. I understand the pressures,
especially in China, around becoming
successful, so you can get your apartment
and start your family. I'm aware.
Everybody's got pressure.
- [Yuanhao] Hi, Gary!
After I learned something
about you, I am pretty
interested in how the
idea of online shopping
came up with you
and made you so successful.
I don't think only luck is enough
for such things to happen.
Besides, how can we predict
the future, or in other words,
how can we know what the
world would be like, especially what
kind of things may be
popular in the future?
Can you give us a suggestion
on how we should think?
Thank you very much!
- [Gary] You're welcome very much.
1996.
Ebay was around.
Amazon was around.
The world hadn't accepted its upside.
I bet on consumer behavior
and innovation and things changing.
So I can predict the future.
Were there five? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Were there 5 liquor stores in America
that had online stores
when I launched? No.
So it feels like I'm predicting
the future, but I'm taking innovation
that's happening around me,
and I'm deploying it against my own
reality at that time.
My bet was that we would pick
convenience over history.
Because that's what humans always do
and that's why it was so obvious.
It'd be the same reason
that I know that AI is going
to be very important.
It's the same reason that I
know voice is very important.
All the things, my friend, about
the future, are happening right now.
The question is, "Have you calibrated
how big they are going to be in
7 to 10 years, and are you
looking the other way while it's right
in your face?" I've been
very good at understanding
the arbitrages of attention and
infrastructure that drive business over
the last 20 years, and I
plan on doing it for the
next 50 years of my life. So for me,
I'm giving it to you right now.
Whether it's using KOLs
to drive your business,
whatever it may be,  right? There are
so many opportunities out there
that are so black-and-white obvious.
Yet, we tend to look
the other way because
there's no historical reference
point directly to that attribution.
But there is. Celebrities have been
selling products for 100 years.
There's just new celebrities, got it?
So my punchline is very simply:
The future is always the present.
If you're guessing the future, you're guessing.
If you're moving quickly in the reality,
it seems like you're predicting,
but you're just reacting.
You like that one, right?
That was a good one.
-[Rhys] Can we ask one?
-[Gary] Yeah, of course!
Was that it for them?
Go ahead, you get to ask one.
-[Rhys] My question is:
In China, Alipay
WeChat,
Google payments...
are in the trillions.
In the U.S., only
$60 billion maybe
from mobile payments...
-[Gary] Because there's fragmentation.
So go ahead, what's it going to take?
-[Rhys] I'm saying, why is the
U.S. lagging behind?
- [Gary] The reason the U.S.
is lagging behind is because the
giant internet companies in
China are fully integrated.
If Apple and Facebook merged
tomorrow, you'd have it. The end.
I mean, it's just the dynamics.
Look, there's one thing that
people give credit to the Chinese
entrepreneurs that isn't
taken into account,
which is the government involvement
matters. That's not how the U.S. works.
Steve jobs wasn't able to call at
the time, [President] George Bush, and say,
"You know that Facebook thing
that's emerging? Yeah, I need that."
I love when... Listen, as
you can see, my energy
so pro-Asia, plenty pro-China.
But we can't forget that
the "big dogs" had competitive
government advantages that
created a full stack.
In the U.S., it's called
Apple, Amazon, and Facebook.
In China, it's just all integrated.
Is there one more?
-[Skipper] There was one question from
the guy who just left. Darren.
[Background chat]
-[Gary] Yeah, why don't you
ask one. I think we're good.
-[Skipper] Actually, the
one  that I prepared,
I asked in the back...
- [Gary] While we're hanging out
here having a good time...
What you're seeing, what you're
vibing, is just a very thoughtful,
exciting moment in my career.
To me, looking at the
Asian market is almost as
wide open and as exciting
as when I started Vaynermedia,
or when I started to get involved
involved my Dad's business with
Wine Library or when I
discovered the internet or when
social media Web 2.0 was
emerging from the Web 1.0, era.
You've got a question?
- [Skipper] It's from Darren.
OK, go ahead. I was
on such a good rant...
Nah.. I mean... Punchline being,
this expansion into the Asian
market both in Mainland China and
surrounding marketplaces is
going  to be a really fun frontier.
Go ahead.
-[Skipper] So this question
is from Darren.
He asked about
"How does one start
a process of architecting
one's business?"
and "When you are architecting
your own business, how do you
gain support for an unpopular decision?"
"How do you convince your
team to work on it?"
- [Gary] Yeah. So you convince
your team by one of two things.
Either motivating them through
enormous optimism or forcing them
through dark dictatorship.
The middle one --- The first one is
how you begin to architect
is backwards.
You try to figure out
what you're doing backwards.
You're trying to figure out
why you're doing it and
what the opportunity is, and
then once you understand ---
So for me, when I started
Vaynermedia. Oh, my God.
Oh, wow, there's a lot
of reasons why the biggest
companies in the world
don't market properly.
They're not smart enough?
Not really.
They don't care?
Kind of. But wait a minute.
There are four major marketing
companies that dictate the entire
world, and they're pushing the
profitable items for themselves.
And there's not a lot
of talent that sees where
the world is going. What if
I built a machine
that was so incredible at
marketing that then when
I bought brands in the future,
and I ran it through them,
I could take the value
of a brand like K-Swiss
from $100 to $500 million
in sales very quickly because I
only did influencer marketing.
I only did Facebook.
I only did...OK. Why don't
I do that? OK.
Now, the way I'm going
to do that is I'm going to
build an agency that only
sells the best work.
It won't be popular at first,
but I have to do it
because my long-term vision
requires me being the best marketer
of the future and more importantly
the best at that time. OK.
I'm going to hire a bunch of kids at
first, because no "real" marketer
is going to want to work for me,
because I'm going to tell them
TV is bullshit and banner ads are
bullshit and radios are bullshit.
This is 2009.
They don't believe in Facebook
and Twitter, but I do.
So let me get a bunch
of kids and I'll show them
I'll teach them.
They're fresh-eyed.
They don't have preconceived notions.
Then I'll pick up market share
and then when the biggest
brands in the world realize
they have to use it, I'll pick
up early market share and
learn to....That's how you
do it. You start backwards.
I started with my ambition to buy the Jets.
How am I going to do that?
Flip businesses.
By building a machine
around my marketing skill.
Then getting people to
buy-in is pretty easy,
and then the middle one is my
favorite. Making unpopular decisions.
I only make unpopular decisions.
DRock was an unpopular decision.
Everybody told me that was
super narcissistic. It's very weird.
The fuck do you have somebody
following you around for?
And I thought that was
probably a great idea...
To me, the second I feel
a lot of push back,
and I actually thought of it,
and I thought it was a good idea?
Then I know I've got something big.
So those are my answers.
Do you have the self-esteem and
the confidence and the ability
to do all those things
is a whole different story.
Anyway, Asia is going to be good.
Great trip and I really appreciate
everybody watching.
My question of the day:
"When you think about
the Asian tech ecosystem,
- And I'll throw the whole
kit and caboodle into it.
Take it any angle that you want -
what are the first things
that come to mind?"
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(Upbeat music)